welcome to the monitor as always I am
Peter Rubin senior editor at senior
editor at Wired they're going to stop
doing this one of these weeks I promise
this week we're going to talk about
throwback album we're going to talk
about a throwback video game and believe
it or not we're actually going to talk
about kind of a throwback movie so let's
start with that and that is the dodeca
pentathlon I know it's a mouthful from
brothers Jay and Mark Duplass the
duplass brothers who made their bones a
five six seven years ago making a series
of tiny little indie movies that were
lumped in with the mumblecore movement
and then in 2010 they made the movie
Cyrus which was one of my favorite
movies of that year and then they kind
of went into another orbit but in 2008
before they made Cyrus they made this
movie the dodeca pentathlon they shot at
in 2008 but they never had a chance to
go back and finish it until now they
have finally done that and now it is out
this week and it is a story of two
brothers neither of which is Mark
Duplass so you actually might recognize
from acting in their movies and also
being a regular on the league on FX and
a number of other movies story of two
brothers who threw out their teams
competed in this dodeca pentathlon that
they created themselves and now it ended
up souring their relationship and they
have come back together as grown-ass men
to decide things once and for all with a
final dodeca pentathlon there I said it
correctly at any rate is out this week
it's a limited run in theaters but it is
also if you don't live in a city
probably going to be a little tougher to
find but it's also but it's also going
to be on iTunes so actually it doesn't
matter Thank You technology for that so
the dodeca pentathlon is out and you
will see it because i beseech you to
please but now we're going to talk about
the throwback video game portion of the
evening and by evening i mean whenever
we're actually taping this i exist in
strange misty netherworld so let's go to
you for that okay throwback video game
of the week cthulhu saves the world
throwback for two reasons first reason
this is actually came out at the very
end of 2010 for Xbox Live and then came
out last summer for the PC it's just out
now for the iOS second layer of
throwback
saves the world that's really hard to
say cthulhu saves the world is actually
a love letter and homage to the RPGs the
role-playing games in the 16-bit era on
Super Nintendo tales of phantasia Dragon
Quest Chrono Trigger etc it's just like
those Z Boyd games made this with love
it is the tale of HP Lovecraft's famous
Cthulhu creature coming back and having
to break a curse and save the world
little fourth wall breaking is just it
is so it's so love packed you feel the
love dripping from the game and only a
dollar 99 on the App Store just came out
last week well worth the purchase it's
much more than just a port Z board games
made sure that they brought this over
with the love that it deserved and the
love that they have of the genre Cthulhu
saves the world app store last week pick
it out pick it up pick it out then pick
it up pack it up pack it in let me begin
back to you okay thanks for that to be
honest I'm kind of surprised you can
pronounce Cthulhu but good on you for
that so that was the throwback video
game talk about the throwback album
which isn't actually throwback album
because it just came out last week but
it is a throwback sound rkelly of all
people in 2010 came out with this
fantastic album full of throwback
sounding rmb and he has done it again
with the album write me back that came
out last year there for the past few
years there's been this great resurgence
of our being soul artists who are going
back to older styles raphael saadiq has
done it obviously newer guys like Nick
Waterhouse and mayer hawthorne have done
it and r.kelly did it in 2010 and he's
doing it again now and write me back
kind of spans from 50 sounding stuff
through to almost disco Lee Barry White
type production but it's it's pretty
varied and it's pretty great he's in a
strange way he's at his best when he's
writing songs that don't rely on bizarre
sex metaphors and he's just kind of
doing these straight ahead love songs
and songs of you know heartbreak and
repentance and and so it's great for
that and it's shockingly good and to end
listen so that is write me back rkelly
throw it on for
ever seduction you have planned you know
that's on you i'm not going to pry so
that is it for this week on the monitor
hey next week we're going to be a comic
con going to be a comic con is going to
be good times for everyone until then
email us at the monitor at wired.com let
me know what we're missing let me know
what we need to cover let me know I
swear to you I'm gonna get a new pair of
shoes one of these days but until then
and until I see you next week
inspirational catchphrase here